نحذر الفريق المتنفذ في السلطه من تبعات
هذا الاجتماع
كما نحملها المسؤوليه الكامله عن نتائجه
الكارثيه
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم مسؤولون فلسطينيون
واسرائيليون يقل الى اجتماعا في مدينه
العقبه بمشاركه اردنيه ومصريه وامريكيه
وزير الخارجيه الاردنيه اكد ضروره التوصل
الى اتفاق على وقف الاجراءات الاحاديه
تمهيدا لفتره تهدئه في حين قالت الفصائل
ان المشاركه الفلسطينيه في الاجتماع جريمه
وطنيه لا يمكن السكوت عنها مقتل مستوطنين
اثنين في عمليه اطلاق نار قرب بلده حواره
في نابلس والجيش الاسرائيلي يعزز قواته
ويغلق بلدات وقرى في المنطقه ويبدا بعمليه
تمشيط واسعه بحثا عن المهاجمين ومصادر
اسرائيليه تقول ان النار اطلقت من سياره
عابره باتجاه سياره مستوطنين من مسافه
قريبه جدا
بوتا يتهم الغرب بالسعي لتفكيك روسيا
ويؤكد ان النيتو شريك غير مباشر كما يحدث
باوكرانيا وعلى الارض معارك محتدمه في
دنيا والقوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها ستكون
مستعده لهجوم مضاد في الربيع لاستعاده كل
الاراضي بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم في
ماساه انسانيه جديده مصرع خمسه واربعين
طالب لجوء بينهم اطفال بعد تحطم قاربهم
قباله سواحل ايطاليا الجنوبيه حيث كان
عالمتنه نحو 120 لاجئا في حين عبرت رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه عن حزنها العميق وتعهدت
بوقف الهجره عبر البحر
الى اللقاء